what is your story I was are Kelly's
hair braider for about two years I was
sexually abused by him and I live after
that
I'll try to pick up the pieces every day
it's hard but I know I'll get through it
I'm not ashamed of my past anymore do
you feel like this is a moment for you
where you get to tell your truth and
people will listen this is a release
I've been carrying this since 2003 I had
to sit on a public bus and watch the
public conversation did you hear about
what they did with our Kelly they need
to leave that man alone
and I can't stand up for myself when I
finally realized I don't want to be this
victim I don't want to be a part of this
every time I tried to pick myself up
again I felt like something on the news
brought me back to what I thought I
swept under the rug today today I say no
more you can talk about me you can not
like what I'm saying about your favorite
singer but this is my life this is my
truth this is what I have if I died
tomorrow I know that I told the truth I
know that I want to be the best person I
could be I know that I want to help
people if it's anybody that want to
speak the truth it's hard when it's a
celebrity it's not easy it's not easy if
it wasn't a celebrity it makes it 10
times worse